impression offset impression numérique
ou encore création d'affichés
électrogènes aux expos ses savoir-faire
pour ses 70 ans et pour l'événement les
clients peuvent découvrir les machines
et les 1800 m² de la nouvelle filiale
j'étais print une entreprise installée à
trappes depuis 1968 et qui permet au
groupe de compléter l'offre de ces
services soient les clients viennent
avec un bris ou alors juste avec une
idée on va leur proposer donc la
création de ces documents dans le but de
faire soit du web soin d'imprimer ces
documents sur différents supports luxe
btp pharmacie énergie
les clients de groupes septuagénaire se
sont diversifiés avec le temps les
demandes également tous nos clients nous
confient énormément de petit peu gilles
travaux différents
ces travaux vont de la créa l'impression
offset sur les gros volumes des volumes
moyens voire des volumes à un exemplaire
et dans des formats aussi atypique que
la toute petite forme à une forme des
coupes particulière ou une très grand
format et on se charge aussi de poser la
signalétique on a imprimé chez nos
clients
le groupe électro gélose compte
désormais 300 salariés dont 45 pour sa
filiale trappistes une filiale qui
réalise jusqu'à 7 millions d'euros
annuels de chiffre d'affaires